YouTube plays Me by putting another ad
in it okay I see it
will read 450. actually
the actual retail price as well 250 damn
our titties are bouncing up and down
guys
[Applause]
if you want to kiss me you go right
ahead assault can't do it can't do that
you want to kiss me you'll go right
ahead you want to touch my touch me down
there
touch me down there what do we got I'm
owner the guy
do you gotta give me a little kiss right
there you could give me a little kiss
you want to touch me down there what do
we got bring home the guy
dude we've got pregame
what's behind door number what's behind
the zipper what's behind the zipper a
slight jizz
Johnny said you weren't getting much
lately so oh he did oh
you can't believe everything Johnny says
wow Johnny is Jimmy Neutron all grown up
I suppose I should explain that John
does a warm-up that is the only x-rated
warm-up in Hollywood
let's win that prize right over there I
know jukebox dude
imagine a jukebox dude imagine like you
get a dude you can get more music in
this thing here this big than a [__]
jukebox a huge big jukebox that's gonna
stain the thing about the Jukebox it's
gonna stay in your garage and you're
gonna play it and use it a little bit to
play stuff like the Beatles and David
Hasselhoff and maybe one black musician
and then you're gonna keep it and it's
five million pounds Energy box
2953 get the [__] out of here get the
[__] two thousand dollars for a [__]
uh jukebox in
1983 bro
holy [__] you can get a [__] iPhone
for half that
now we will give you that jukebox we
will give you that jukebox if you keep
more than you give away in the give or
keep game there's six worst games ever
you know two prizes at a time each time
let's play a game flip the card what are
you gonna do what do you think it is a
jack oh it's a queen oh did you win or
lose we don't even know it's just stupid
oh confusing the game dude look the game
dude and they explain it
there's six prizes there I'll show you
two prizes at a time each time you keep
surprise you believe is higher priced
okay what are you gonna do keep the
higher price you got it the first two
prizes for your consideration are a
range and with the range a spice right
oh my God I mean old people [__] eat
dishes right on the table this monthly
double burner Buffet rain and it's nine
million dollars
except for the adjustable temperature
controls the guy hates his job a spice
rack room oh God I mean the guy's got to
read off a spice rack
or a spice rack McCormick Schilling
spice rack we got a bunch of different
spices on here like thyme like Rosemary
it's got a bunch of different spices
there's a bunch of grains and [__] in it
anyway what's the [__] price of it
especially with the finest and spices
and seasoning
Wave oven is your house how could they
not be drunk doing this if harness the
spices and find us the spices It Anyways
got time on it
time t-h-y-m-e not to confuse me with
the clock car [__] so how much is this
goddamn thing
from McCormick Shelley McCormick Donna
you wish to keep
[Music]
[Applause]
check them off
[Music]
range okay how much is the spice rack
fifty dollars that goes into the give
column fifty dollars in the give column
coming out on the turntable they better
not demonetize us because this is a
[__] hole
a tea set tea set and a watch story of
both Mr Olson I love this armatron sun
moon oh my god dude watch has four digit
readouts the watch more minutes seconds
for day Moon shows for night or this
10-piece Brittany ceramic service
includes covered pot I don't know it's a
bunch of pots or something anyway what
do you [__] want some Rattan serving
God I wish I could are you are going to
keep the watch or the tea set tea set
the tea set how much is it what they
have to have it more the watch is 20
bucks and a jukebox is [__] five
grand
[Music]
lightweight iron Silverstone so play for
no snag all right so so what now the
iron is 35. the iron goes so
[__] boring so far
reading off the what do you want the
knife or the [__] range well you want
the range okay you got a range you got a
range the ranges I got two things on it
and the ranger thing it gets red if it
gets hot then you get you put a [__]
pot on it and it boils the water oh
35 in the give column now we're going to
get so boring
[Music]
God that's boring dude get in it
look at this first comment R.I.P Johnny
Olson watching this in 2022 you really
miss the old days when people behave
correctly
you know wow I know I'm surroundings I
know right different world back then
wow
dude the [__] comments bro sort of
the the driving force behind the show's
success was the audience is
unprecedented quick honest natural and
genuine Behavior authentic spontaneous
Applause and fun this is the spiritist
move move
move-ins movement of the huge success
and popularity of the show dude all
right at 1978 TVP the [__] out of here
and let's get down to business and win
another prize should we let's win that
prize right over
there what is it some flies
you got flies you're buzzing around you
gotta oblige you try to read and the
Flies are buzzing around your eyes you
got a bunch of you're trying to cook the
Flies are laying eggs in your [__]
pot roast and then they got a bunch of
[__] maggots and poop is all in your
Pirates better at it before they [__]
grow and they won't grow on your belly
don't worry because they'll just be dead
in your belly they need air and you [__]
them out and you're flush down until
it's all good the Flies be dead so here
we go so dear what do you want to bid
for the Flies
ah [__] dude
that's good man
ah [__] man just super good man
I'd love to give you that
[Music]
[Applause]
do it the way they do it
do it
look at the car too here have you heard
about this [__] dude pleasure to me it's
nice to meet you now Josh my boy I'd
love to give you that
[Music]
hell yeah dude look at Roddy Rod look at
Rod standing over there
calm cool
dude what
what the [__]
does this guy look like oh my God a
[__] dick Tracy character
he's in a dress idea Huey do dress like
a hundred percent what's his name
um are you looking at him right now
dressed like Steve Harvey in 1995.
unfucking wearing the last thing Bernie
Mac wore before he deceased on believe
body Rod smoked so many poles it's
unbelievable Roddy Rod was so gay and
it's okay but he was he would just be
like face [__] me
make me just I get off on you telling me
what to do I don't even need to come
let's jerk off in your new car
I'm hurting my voice so bad
and collected but not so only a half
hour or so ago our beloved they're
having so much it was almost the hate to
her by an automobile on stage
because it was a stick shift and the
young lady whose name I shall not
mention in the car doesn't know her
break from her clutch uh sexiest dude
she's a [__] the only jobs you could
have is a nurse is coming on stage the
automobile headed for Rod
and she kept stepping on the clutch
screaming the break won't work
and Rod stood there smiling until the
very last moment and then believe it or
not oh man God left from the stage into
the audience nice dude
that's true and he keeps saying dude
this guy wow I want a documentary on
Roddy Rod right now dude
face [__]
mistress make a Superman cake for him to
wear
[Applause]
Bob this one nearly ran me down it's the
Mitsubishi Mirage four-door sedan with a
clutch
God it's so good dude rest in peace Bob
Barker rest in peace
Roddy Roddy Rod Rod Roddy Rod Roddy dude
wow a candy bar in the [__] 60s and
uh the new Rod Roddy with almonds
um killed it great
what's this one oh here's Roddy Rod
sorry well no I'm not sorry this is
funny [__]
hi a candelabra on your Podium over
there
thank you Bob thank you very much who is
our next player it happens to be Vicki
Fields come on down
[Music]
dude I wonder why they got this guy to
do it like just have Bob Barker do it
Becky helps
that's great
TV was just different
huh remember appointment television dude
like if you wanted to watch a show you
had to [__] sit down at 9 00 pm
come on and you missed dude if you got
there late you missed it
what bro that's crazy I I remember that
all right I'm 43 years old I remember
that and I still am like no way no way
on freaking real dude